the story of a high school introvert and
the performance of an iconic actress
took top honors at the Tonys the seasons
breakout hit
dear Evan Hanson and the legendary Bette
Midler were among the big winners a
dozen of Broadway's best shows will
recognize last night with Awards first
time host Kevin Spacey brought a stable
of impressions and some famous friends
to the stage CBS News contributor Jamie
wax was there Jamie good morning good
morning Nora that's right without one
show to run the table like Hamilton did
last year the competition for a Tony
Award was a welcome change it was also a
time to celebrate Broadway's biggest
season at the box office first time host
Kevin Spacey kicked off the Tonys with
the kind of range that helped him on his
first Tony over 25 years ago and he
brought out a cast of his favorite
characters I love the Toni's I do there
were impersonations of Bill Clinton I
knew they needed a host Johnny Carson
here's the envelope and a special
appearance by President Frank Underwood
from house of cards Late Show host
Stephen Colbert performed with Spacey in
the opening number and presented the
Award for Best revival of a musical
tonight we have three amazing nominees
Hello Dolly this revival features an
up-and-comer on Broadway named I want to
get this right
betta Midler keep an eye on her I hear
very good things this was a season
without a clear front-runner so Tony
voters decided to spread the love a
dozen shows shared the major awards
[Music]
this is a Tony hello
okay then Platt won the Tony for Lead
Actor in a musical the woman who played
his mother Rachel Bay Jones one for
featured actress in a musical
dear Evan Hanson and their show dear
Evan Hanson was the big winner of the
night with six Awards when you started
with this project and it was so small
did you see it getting as big as it's
become certainly I did not have any idea
that it would get as big as it has but
yeah it's a phenomenon Bette Midler
Helen but Tony night may have belonged
to Bette Midler the actress took home
her first competitive Tony more than 50
years after making her Broadway debut I
have so many people to thank I'd like to
thank the American Theatre Wing to begin
with and all the Tony voters many of
whom I have actually dated and not even
the band could play her off the stage
Hamilton wasn't completely out of the
building lin-manuel Miranda handed out
the award for Best Musical and two
members of the show's creative team won
awards for new shows so that was that
was good Hamilton is still feeling a
presence on Broadway and the show
getting rave reviews Kevin Spacey's
impressions were dead-on I thought it
was a great side of him to see seem a
little playful he is great at the
impressions and I thought the special
guests were great too
really good broadcast is Hamilton doing
well in terms of productions around the
world it is doing really well in fact I
mean I think it's probably projected to
be a global phenomenon on the level of
say Lion King which at one point was
earning more every week in its live
productions than the entire box office
of the film The Lion King in its
theatrical right
yeah or you were there with your
favorite younger daughter you two look
great thank you thank you really good
lot of fun I thought it was fun reading
in all the pieces too about how Broadway
has had such a resurgence sales are up
that's right everybody loves the theater
more people are coming and they're
charging 800 bucks for premium seats so
that's why the numbers are breaking
records it's working Thank You Jamie
Thanks